[Music]
in news we didn't expect to hear in 2017
Netflix has announced a new series based
on Castlevania there's not much in the
way of details but we have heard what
the show will be like from Netflix and
some of its producers I'm Matt and what
a fantastic night to have a GameSpot
news update the Netflix press release
says inspired by the classic video game
series Castlevania is a dark medieval
fantasy following the last surviving
member of the disgraced Belmont clan
trying to save Eastern Europe from
extinction at the hand of Vlad Dracula
tepe himself the show is written by
x-men veteran Warren Ellis an executive
produced by Ellis Kevin cold Fred
Seibert
and Adi Shankar last year Shankar said
on Facebook I'm producing a super
violent Castlevania miniseries with my
homies Fred Seibert and Kevin Kolb it's
going to be dark satirical and after a
decade of propaganda it will flip the
vampire sub-genre
on its head the first part of
castlevania season 1 is set to release
in 2017 but no specific premiere date
was given we'll keep you updated as
further information is revealed so for
that and more from the world the video
games stay tuned the game spot